Less than 25 years after New Yorkers
vowed to never forget, they decided to
take a huge steaming crap all over the
victims of the 9/11 attacks by electing
a failed rapper who openly praises
jihadis.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Yes, that was New York City Mayor Zohran
Mamdani praising the Holy Land Five, a
group of men who were sentenced to a
total of 180 years in prison for running
a charity that collected donations in
the US and funneled these donations to
Hamas.
Muslims around the world are celebrating
the new Muslim mayor, seen here posing
in front of a sign that says God is gay.
But not all Muslims are happy about
Mamdani. Some Muslims don't think he
actually knows much about Islam. For
instance, Beck Lover reacted to Mamdani
swearing on the Quran with this.
First of all, in Islam, you are not
allowed to swear on the Quran. The only
thing you can swear on is God. Second of
all, the last thing you would place on
the Quran is your left hand, which is
what Muslims used to wash their behinds.
It would be the right hand.
Just an FYI for all the people going
crazy about Mamdani in New York, another
Soros funded politician.
So, we don't really know how devout
Mamdani is, but we do know what's in the
Quran his left hand was on.
Let's read a few verses. Surah 98 verse
6.
Verily, those who disbelieve in the
religion of Islam, the Quran, and
Prophet Muhammad, blah blah blah, from
among the people of the scripture, Jews
and Christians, and Al-Mushrikun,
Mushrikun are people who associate
partners with Allah
will abide in the fire of hell. They are
the worst of creatures.
According to Mamdani's Quran, Jews and
Christians are the worst of creatures.
We're lower than dogs, we're lower than
pigs, we're lower than insects.
What about Muslims? Well, according to
Surah 3 verse 110, Muslims are the best
of peoples ever raised up for mankind.
Jews and Christians are the worst of
creatures, Muslims are the best of
peoples ever raised up for mankind.
Not surprisingly, since Jews and
Christians are the worst of creatures,
while Muslims are the best of peoples,
Muslims aren't supposed to be friends
with us.
Surah 5 verse 51.
O you who believe, do not take the Jews
and the Christians for friends. They are
friends of each other. And whoever
amongst you takes them for a friend,
then surely he is one of them. Surely
Allah does not guide the unjust people.
Allah says that if you take a Jew or a
Christian as a friend, you're not really
a Muslim. You're a Jew or a Christian.
But there's an exception to the rule,
according to Surah 3 verse 28, where
Allah says,
Let not the believers take disbelievers
for their friends in preference to
believers. Whoso doeth that hath no
connection with Allah, unless it be that
he but guard yourselves against them,
taking, as it were, security.
Allah biddeth you beware only of
himself. Unto Allah is the journeying.
Notice, don't take disbelievers for
friends when you can just be friends
with fellow Muslims, unless it's to
guard yourselves against them.
What does this mean?
Well, if you're in a country where
Muslims are totally outnumbered and it
wouldn't be in the best interest of the
Muslim community to be viewed as
hostile, you can pretend to be friendly
towards non-Muslims.
And that's how Muhammad's companions
understood this verse.
Here's Ibn Kathir's commentary on 3:28.
He quotes two of Muhammad's companions.
Allah said next, unless you indeed fear
a danger from them, meaning except those
believers who in some areas or times
fear for their safety from the
disbelievers.
In this case, such believers are allowed
to show friendship to the disbelievers
outwardly, but never inwardly. For
instance, Al-Bukhari recorded that Abu
Ad-Darda said, "We smile in the face of
some people, although our hearts curse
them."
Al-Bukhari said that Al-Hasan said, "The
tuqyah, that's taqiyya,
is allowed until the day of
resurrection."
So, when Muslims can't hope to win a
physical confrontation with the
unbelievers, they're allowed to pretend
to be friendly.
But eventually, when their numbers
increase, they can show their hostility,
as we read in Surah 48 verse 29.
Muhammad is the messenger of Allah, and
those who are with him are severe
against disbelievers and merciful among
themselves. Severe against disbelievers,
merciful only among themselves.
Sounds like a great recipe for a
two-tier society.
Ultimately, non-Muslims have to be
violently subjugated. Surah 9 verse 29.
Fight those who do not believe in Allah
nor in the latter day, nor do they
prohibit what Allah and his apostle had
prohibited, nor follow the religion of
truth out of those who had been given
the book, Jews and Christians, until
they pay the tax in acknowledgement of
superiority and they are in a state of
subjection.
The tax here is the jizya, which is
tribute money Jews and Christians pay
Muslims in order to acknowledge our
inferiority and not be executed.
Here's Ibn Kathir's commentary.
Paying jizya is a sign of kufr,
unbelief, and disgrace. Allah said,
"Until they pay the jizya, if they do
not choose to embrace Islam,
with willing submission in defeat and
subservience and feel themselves
subdued, disgraced, humiliated, and
belittled.
Therefore, Muslims are not allowed to
honor the people of dhimma or elevate
them above Muslims, for they are
miserable, disgraced, and humiliated."
So, those are a few highlights or
lowlights from the book Mamdani's
butt-wiping hand was on as he took his
oath of office. Westerners, it seems,
are hell-bent on proving how tolerant
and open-minded we are by constantly
empowering the followers of a book that
calls for our violent subjugation.
On the bright side,
now that Mamdani is mayor,
maybe we'll never have to hear him rap
again.
>> [music]
[music]